ce matin je suis tombé par hasard sur
mon horoscope aujourd'hui les astres
s'alignent et une nouvelle page s'ouvre
à vous aux objectifs semblent plus que
jamais atteignable et certains rêves
vont se réaliser mais marzouk est alors
attention de ne pas vous laisser
engourdir par vos souvenirs on voit
qu'elle avait plutôt tapé juste parce
que poutine sinon la rampe à tuer saison
pour une fois qu'il n'est pas de la
garde qui a acheté kaulitz alban tout le
monde vous a vu avec la petite hasek
collins aller vers le bassin elle n'est
jamais revenue
il entretenait quels rapports votre mari
a donc lâché collins et pourquoi tu es
parti à los angeles du jour au lendemain
il ya un truc je suis partout ces cas
chez soi par piano sans gêne et sans
toit c'est pour ça que tu l'as biton peu
sur elle que je me suis arraché s'est
pas passé comme ça je te présente le
nouveau maître tony ça m'étonnait et
comme c'est une grosse [ __ ] et bat
escarpé que mon mec mais c'est pas moi
je dis c'est pas moi c'est que je suis
pas du tout cette petite conne qui rêve
d'être semblait alors c'est un malheur
de t'approcher du père de mes enfants je
te je t'écoute
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous avez fait à cette
soirée avec ashley
tout à fait je sais pas football quoi
dans sept jours
si tu mets sur orange tu as la
possibilité de voir cette série en
amenant à people tv tu peux y aller
parce que le premier mois est gratuit et
si tu veux te faire de sketches là
maintenant tout de suite tu peux aller
directement sur notre chaîne qui
s'appelle comme nous à maurice quentin
est pareil le premier mois gratuit tu
verras ya plusieurs sketchs vous allez
tout le temps gratuit mais je peux tu as
donné tu peux tu peux c'est à modéré